que serait Noël sans cadeaux Clara vous
nous proposez quelques idées de cadeau
100 % ivelinois on commence avec des
savons Artis ano et écologique élaboré à
carrière souspissie oui c'est bain
d'étoil fondé par Magalie Cochet Blin
qui propose ses savons naturels éthique
et écoresponsable ils sont entièrement
produits à carrière souspoissie à partir
d'ingrédients issus de l'agriculture
biologique fabriqué moulé et découpé à
la main elle utilise une méthode
ancestrale de la saponisation à froid
chaque année l'artisane produit près de
4000 savons vous pouvez les retrouver
dans sa boutique situé à poissi vous
aurez le choix entre les savons pour le
corps pour le visage mais aussi pour les
cheveux parce que oui bain d'étoile
fabrique ces shampoings solides ils
conviennent à tous les types de peau et
à tous les types de cheveux et ils sont
disponibles à partir de 5 €. vous les
connaissez bien Gabriel c'est ça oui
j'avais tourné un reportage avec Magal C
chez Blin et oui tout est fait maison
donc un beau cadeau iblinois et donc si
vous souhaitez aller plus loin bain
d'étoil propose aussi des SAV avons tous
usage à l'huile de coco il utilise il
s'utilise pardon pour laver la vaisselle
le linge ou pour les différentes
surfaces de la maison compté à partir de
2,50 € pour ce produit pour les plus
indécis ne vous inquiétez pas j'ai aussi
pensé à vous la boutique propose aussi
des coffrets de savon à partir de 18 €.
et alors pour le prochain cadeau Clara
vous nous emmenez au musée de la toile
de jouis à jouill en Josas et plus
précisément dans sa boutique qui propose
des créations originales inspirées de
motifs de la toile de jouit fabriqué par
des artisans locaux vous pourrez y
trouver toutes sortes de produits
décoration d'intérieur vêtements pour
femmes et hommes papéterie accessoires
ou encore hard de la table et il y en a
pour tous les goûts et pour tous les
prix compte 5,90 € pour un assortiment
de carte postale 14,50 pour un carnet ou
encore 35 € pour une bougie et son
pochon la boutique est ouverte du mardi
au dimanche aux heures d'ouverture du
musée mais si vous souhaitez il existe
également une boutique en ligne et c'est
très à la mode la toile de
jou c'est vrai que les grands créateurs
s'en inspirent régulièrement pour leur
nouvelle collection oui un cadeau
original et à la mode du
coupinois toutes les cases et alors pour
la dernière idée de cadeau Clara vous
nous emmenez aux EOS safari de toiri oui
si vous cherchez un cadeau assez
original et qui fera plaisir à coup sûr
je vous propose d'offrir un passe annuel
pour le zoau toiri une expérience
immersive en plein cœur de la faune et
de la flore en illimité et sans
restriction pendant 1 an vous pourrez
traverser le safari en voiture pour
observer les animaux du parc dans un
espace ouvert si vous préférez une
rencontre plus intime avec ces animaux
il est aussi possible d'explorer le parc
à pied vous pourrez y croiser 750
animaux et 110 espèces différentes le
pass annuel est à 62 € pour les adultes
et à 45 € pour les enfants âgés de 3 à
11 ans et pour prolonger l'expérience il
est maintenant possible aussi d'offrir
une nuit au plus près des animaux oui
depuis le 20 octobre dernier le zoo
safari de toiri propose désormais cinq
lodges de luxe pour vivre au rythme des
éléphants compé 680 € la nuit pour deux
personnes le tarif comprend 2 jours
d'entrée au parc les repas une visite
privative de la maison des éléphants
ainsi qu'un un entraînement médical pour
les plus aventuriers vous pouvez aussi
choisir de dormir à côté des ours et des
loups dans des tanières en pleine nature
compté à partir de 150 € la nuit par
personne